All right.
Izhar.
Thank you for being with us.
Thank you for being my kind host
overseas this evening.
Of course, of course.
Twelve thousand kilometers
Not keeping us apart, even in times of
Corona.
Absolutely.
So, Parliament member and former VC
.
and a CEO and entrepreneur
and social entrepreneur and all around,
incredible leader.
One of the best that I know.
It's not going to do justice if we even
start to talk a bit
about about what you did.
Can you can you share a little bit about
some of the things that
you've done over the past several
dozen years
and some of the things that excite you?
Oh, well
You know, I started my career as a
as an electronics engineer and then
moved on to all kinds of capacities.
I think that my most exciting times
were spent as an entrepreneur.
I enjoyed very much taking ideas into
products, into customers' hands
into building a business around them.
Which I did a number of times.
Two of them were with the
venture backed companies
that I had the privilege of running.
Both of them realized successful
exits for investors
but that was not the main issue.
the main point was really
seeing your product in the hands
of customers
and positively influencing people
around the world
which was a lot of excitement,
a lot of fun
and, you know, self rewarding
in terms of satisfaction and pride
You know, all those things
that I guess motivate us as individuals
and so I did that
And then I joined a venture capital firm
in the US called Canaan Partners
I was one of a team of
10 people most times where we invested
in companies,
mostly in the US, but also in
Israel and in India
and that was exciting as well, this time
taking a backseat as a board member,
as an investor
hopefully sometimes as a
value add investor
I had a lot of fun
And this was also rewarding in the sense of
having the chance
of working with very talented, bright
people around the world on bringing
their ideas into markets
influencing positively
people around the world
which is again, a lot of fun,
a lot of satisfaction
and you know, it was also
an educating journey just because you
meet with so many bright people
with so many great ideas.
and only you can join some of them
on the journey
that was very exciting as well
so I did all kinds of interesting things,
I guess, the last year plus as wel
we can speak about it
as well if you want
so interesting things,
I think that's putting it a little bit mildly
and we'll get to that.
but as of last year,
you're a Knesset member
and you're now serving the public
serving Israel and you're influencing
and in ways
that are very different from the way an
entrepreneur or a venture capitalist can
and it sounds like a pretty interesting
transition, moving
from high tech, very agile,
move fast and break things
very capitalistic to all of a sudden
serving the public and bringing up
bringing the social good in mind
so why? why at age 55 are you
now standing in the Knesset
and fighting for the good of
the Israeli citizens?
well, you know, one day when
I have the time to
sit down and write my memories,
I'll have to go back to this
specific question and try
to answer it properly
at this time, I can only offer thoughts,
you know, because this is an
ongoing process
I am more than a year into this
it kind of happened all of a sudden,
although I had been
so to speak, in public service
for quite some time
you know, as a volunteer
yes, a venture capitalist
but that aside, as a volunteer
I ran a not for profit organization that
dealt with and still is dealing now
without me, but dealt with the
youth around the country here in Israel
coming from challenging
socio-economic backgrounds
so those young adults were
under the great
support and care of our
volunteers around the country
so I did start for more than 10 years
very hard as a volunteer
on integrating various people
into the Israeli high-tech
you worked with the Haredis as well, right?
say that again
you worked with the Haredis as well, quite a bit
So, yeah.
So my point was trying to
integrate people who
come from communities
which are not necessarily
integrated properly
into the Israeli high-tech,
integrating those people into their high
tech bubble served
two main causes
one of them is just giving them equal
opportunities and providing
them with the appropriate
platform to go about their desires and
so improving their economics
but also there was also a bigger cause,
which was
this is important for the Israeli society
you know, bringing people together from
different communities,
different backgrounds is something
that we are missing badly over here
so I did that,
and then
so, at a certain point
and juncture, I came across
this opportunity of joining the
political life
which was a very tough decision
leaving all those exciting, interesting
and fun lifestyles
and and just to, you know, way of
going about life
that was a lot of fun and
very rewarding personally
and also, you know, the kind of life I
think I would be happy to go back one
day, 20, 30 years from now
so I had to leave all of these behind me
and join the political arena
but I think that they did it
because I understood
that what I did as a volunteer can scale
up in a significant way
If I am willing to take the
responsibility
and willing to  take
upon the challenge
and turn my life completely upside down
from a private entrepreneur
and venture capital to becoming
a public figure
that's a hell of a change
I did this and here I am
I mean, you took you took a really
non-traditional approach
I mean, a lot of politicians, they
started in
politics from a very, very
junior position
and then their dream is to even
hopefully one day become close to being
a Knesset member
and you really jumped into the ship of
some really,
really amazing people
and over a year fought really for democracy
as the main stance more than anything
and now you're talking about
the high tech technology within
government now
those two things don't make sense to me
I mean, when you think of
government, at least
I guess up until my generation and a bit
beyond, you
think of slow moving, you think of
bureaucracy.
you think of it's all about the budget
for this and budget for that
and now you're coming in and saying,
let's do it high tech
what does that mean?
can governments be agile?
can governments pivot when they need to?
wow, you nailed this Michael, right to the point
so, you know, it is a huge challenge
governments are slow, very bureaucratic
huge operations in many cases
unnecessarily big
and with so many processes that
kind of go against innovation,
against agile approaches to anything
and then you go into this and say, I'm
going to introduce change
so, yes, it is a huge challenge,
but it is part of the transformation
any nation with
emphasis on, democratic nations, they
have to go through
so, you know, technology has taken
the world has taken the world
through a
significant breakthrough
and we have all seen a leap forward
of changing the way we run our lives
personally on the business side, on the
community side
everywhere around us, governments are still
way behind and very slow to respond
but governments who want to
to survive have to go through that
transition
you know, your generation will not be
willing to accept
a government that slows down your
personal developmental
your desires, your willingness
to do stuff quickly and efficiently
it's a way of life, right
so here is a huge challenge
I think that I am in a good position to
realize that the need is there,
that it is a critical need, and we have
to start that transition
so, you know, I think that
other people already started this
transition not only in
Israel, but in other democracies like in
the US and elsewhere
there's a lot to be done
and I think that we are
here in Israel in a position,
in a good position
to try to push things forward,
because we are a startup nation
because there are
so many technologies,
breakthrough technologies that are being
developed here
and because we are a small country overall,
the positive noise, the positive
technology
and innovation noise has gone across
just the high tech community
so many people around the country,
some of them
understand the notion of innovation
and they also grew, too,
to know, to demand better from the
government
just because they see things managed
differently elsewhere
and so this is the some sort of a
turning point
where people around
the country realized that
a change is needed, a change is
possible,
and we, the politicians,
have the duty of introducing those
changes
so let me give you a number of examples
we want to provide a
a much better efficient
service to the public.
most of the service where the
government faces the public in Israel
and by the way, elsewhere as well
still requires many face to face interactions
many paper based interactions and
and sort of old world ways
of running your business
so, you know, my vision is hopefully
a number of years from now by law,
all Israeli government offices
and authorities will be required
to have an electronic interface with
anybody who requires
so, you know, I have my parents
they're 80 plus years old
they want to interface person to person,
and that's totally fine
but your generation, you know, you
would probably find it hard to believe
that you need to go somewhere
you need to file a paper, you need to
interface with a clerk
It's really unacceptable
and there's no reason for that
so we have to go through that transition
I should say that a number of Israeli
officers, Israeli governmental officers,
have started to go through that transition
But still, there is a long way to go
luckily, again, we are startup nation.
there are so many technology,
so many products that
have been developed
over here to improve the
efficiency of processes
to provide better service to customers
to manage all kinds of processes
in a much better way
so all of this, interesting enough,
is being sold outside of Israel just
because Israeli entrepreneurs do not
want to deal with the government
rightfully so,
I was an entrepreneur
I have scars of trying to sell to the
Israeli government
so I know what it takes
but if you just improve that facet of the
government,
you suddenly see the Israeli
municipalities taking advantage of so
many smart cities technologies that
have been developed in Israel
but are sold exclusively elsewhere
out of the country
you see so many technologies
that can improve
the efficiency, the productivity,
the security
of government agencies sold elsewhere
that can be integrated into our
government over here
so that's an example
And I just touched upon kind of the
surface
this is a trivial transition
you know, going paperless, going
electronically
and so on, but there are so many other
layers that one could think about
and we have so many good ideas
that, you know,
I could spend the next 20 years or
more integrating
interesting ideas that will be a lot of fun
venture capitalists, you're sitting
and I have the
privilege now
of experiencing a little taste of it
here in Silicon Valley
and, you know, you're sitting there and
you're trying to
think of a business proposition
an opportunity to change consumer
behavior, to improve the lives of many
and then you're sitting on your side of
the table as the venture capitalist
and trying to think, is this viable?
and I grow this into a scalable business
that will actually bring value to people?
and I can't help but make the
comparison that
sitting in the position that you
are now, you're seeing
all these propositions all the time
do you find yourself ever putting on this
venture capitalist hat and trying to assess
whether if this was a startup that came
and proposed
whether I believe this entrepreneur
whether I believe this model that they're
suggesting
oh, absolutely
let me give you an example, Michael
it's an interesting analogy
you know, here's something I learned
every parliament member is actually some
sort of a PNL unit
so really, you know, here in Israel, we
have 120 parliament members
each of whom makes decisions
as to what to focus on and what to
invest their time in
and there are many opportunities to
advance all kinds of laws
all kinds of public services
and one has to focus
one has to decide what is their specific
advantage, what are their desires
and what is that you really
want to promote?
you know, every day, every day,
as a public servant,
I get approached by many people
who rightfully so
have all kinds of interesting ideas
all kinds of desires or
all kinds of problems
and you have to make that decision
you have to make the decision of,
you know,
I want to focus on certain areas
I'm going to specialize in those areas
I want to provide service to
certain constituents
and by doing this, by the way, I realized
that I give up others
so it's not an easy decision
pretty much the same way venture
capitalists work,
you know, as a VC partner
I would see about 1000 opportunities
every year
obviously, as you know, I would have not
been able to
deal with even 1 percent of them
and if I did two to three deals a year,
I would feel pretty good about it
same here
you know, just to give you a sense
the previous full term Knesset
that worked in Israel was the
20th Knesset
it worked for about four years
and it was able to
to put together about 400
plus laws, you know, in Israel
but the number of law proposals
that were submitted were about 6000 law
proposals from the get go
so here's your ratio
if you think about this, about 6000 law
proposals that were filtered in
not by VCs, but by Knesset members
so each of those basic members
probably looked at
at least 3 to 5 times that number
and they decided to narrow down to about
6000 law proposals
and four years later, you see that
about 400.
so I'll say like 7-8% of them
were really transacted
so this is like taking the VC approach
and understanding it and
then kind of mapping it to what
the process looks like in my life today
and frankly, my life as a VC is helpful here
I learned to prioritize, to understand
where my added value stands and
to force myself to focus while realizing
that I may be giving up other
opportunities as well
and you probably can't say it yourself,
but honestly, it probably is from
the VC perspective
you also know sometimes to cut the
bullshit and to
and to get to the point and know some of
the things that go behind
what's actually behind the
PowerPoint presentation
and I'm sure that that gives a lot
of value as well
I can give you
an interesting example
of how all this combines, if you want
yeah, of course
so, you know, these are corona times,
corona virus times, I should say
and one of the things we are, one of the big
challenges we are facing as
the parliament here in Israel is the
significant, realistic, fear that
sometime over the next
few days or few weeks,
we may find many of us,
parliament members
out of the Knesset, out of the parliament
either being instructed to stay home
because we were close
to somebody who was infected
or one or some,
some of us may be infected themselves
so here is the challenge
the Israeli parliament by
a very significant law
we call them foundation laws
this is like the constitution translated
into Israeli terms
we do not have a constitution here, but
we have
basic laws that kind of control the way
we govern our democracy
one of these laws dictates that
any discussion and voting
must take in person in the Knesset
if you are not in the Knesset, you are
not allowed to vote
you are not allowed to be part of
the discussion
and interestingly enough, throughout
the 72 years of the Israeli parliament,
there was never a session that was
prevented from being
handled because of anything
so you know, sometimes
there used to be emergency cases
you know, we were attacked here and
there
so we stopped for 24 hours, but you
continue the
discussion and the voting process so
that democracy continues to run
but nobody ever thought that you may find
a situation where
people cannot go in person to do this
and by the way, we have provisions of
substituting
the Knesset building into some other
building, there are
all kinds of backup buildings
so, gathering is possible
but the notion of doing this
electronically
was never considered
not for technology reasons, but just for
you could call this basic democracy
you want to see the person in person
so I used my experience and submitted an
urgent law proposal to the Knesset
where we are kind of running
against time
you know, it takes time to process law
sometimes it takes two to three years
sometimes it takes a few months
it rarely takes a few days but we're
running against time
and so the clock is ticking
we submitted a law proposal this week,
and we hope to be able to bring it up to
discussion on Monday, next week
which is a record breaking pace
and that law will allow for a limited
amount of time and for very specific
cases, which are people that
have to be isolated
by the orders of the ministry of health,
or they have been infected
but they will be allowed to log in
electronically and they will be allowed to
discuss and to vote, which is a very
significant precedence
we have to go through all the motions,
we sat with top lawyers here in Israel
constitutional lawyers and others
and we have come up with the right
formula that kind of satisfies everybody
and now we are running
against time
the real fear is that we will not
have enough people to vote
on submitting and for an approach in
approving this law before people are
being isolated
so here's a combination of everything
you have the VC guy, the technology guy and
the parliament member
who are trying to put all of
this together
very, very fascinating
wow, best of luck
I mean, that's just inspiring to hear
from my end
Izhar, you have to go back to
running the country
but three words that describe you
wow
dreamier, optimistic, passionate.
I love it
Izhar thank you so, so much
Loved having you here
take good care of yourself, please
take care
stay healthy
bye bye